everyone good morning can you hear me
thank you all for coming and welcome to
Pi data my name is Eric Keenan I'm going
to be one of the volunteers in this
session my goal here is just to help
things go on smoothly so just so you
know these talks are 30 minutes and
we'll have five minutes per question and
then the plan is to have 10 minutes
um
for you all to go wherever you headed
next so this first talk we have krishi
Sharma who will be giving us a talk on
on some of the machine learning tools
that she's working so thank you very
much
hi everyone I'm super stoked to talk to
you about flower but before we go into
what flower is and what Federated
learning is I wanted to talk about data
privacy
since bed rated learning was built to
address concerns around data privacy
I learned what data privacy means for a
company back when I worked at Capital
One in 2019
as an analyst
one day in July I was going into work
perfectly normal day until I got up to
the 11th floor and I saw a bunch of
teams scurrying around there was one
team that was huddled up around a
whiteboard everybody looked super tense
and I thought man I'm glad I'm not them
they look like they're missing a
deadline
but but when I got to my desk and opened
my Slack
I received a message from a co-worker
that said what just happened
exclamation point question mark
exclamation point
and anyone who has gotten a question
with that much punctuation knows that
there's a problem
it turns out that Capital One was the
victim
of a data breach that affected 106
million customers 66 66 000 bank
accounts
somebody at AWS a former employee
hacked into Capital one's Data Warehouse
on AWS
and downloaded all that data
put it onto git while live tweeting the
whole process just in case we wanted
evidence
this severely impacted Capital one's
reputation for the time that when that
happened
because Capital One Believes In
innovating and using new tools such as a
cloud in order to solve problems within
a highly regulated industry like Finance
where data privacy is legally regulated
and of true concern
besides the reputational damage the
stock slipped that morning 5.4 percent
they had to pay 80 million dollars to
the federal bank regulator because of
poor cyber security practices
and they had to pay out 190 million
dollars to all the customers that were
impacted by the data breach
so why should we innovate particularly
in these red taped Industries Why take
the risk of working with such sensitive
data
I mean the truth is I think that there's
so much to gain from building these
Technologies I think that it's Brave and
we need to continue working on using Ai
and machine learning to solve some of
these problems within finance and health
care and we can build our best tools if
only we know how to use the data behind
it
so how do we use private data and
sensitive data to build machine learning
models when there's so much red tape
around them
to really understand that I want to talk
about the challenges that classical
machine learning presents to sensitive
data
In classical machine learning we
typically have a central server that
ends up storing all of the data required
for the model and trains the model
it gets the data from different data
stores or devices
the Red Dot is data
that data is copied from
the different devices let's say your
smartphone or tablet and sent to the
central server
where it is then used
to train a model
so now all of your private data is
in the cloud somewhere with everybody
else's data being used to train a model
the benefit is
the automation that we get with the air
product but the drawbacks are
data privacy and security
what if a data breach happens to that
Central server
we've lost control of our private data
because it's left our device
but also
this isn't highly scalable
because what if we need more compute
than the single machine can give us
so another approach is to look at
distributed machine learning
with distributed machine learning
you typically have your central server
and all of the different devices where
you're getting the data from
the data is again sent to the central
server
but this time instead of the central
server being used to do the compute and
train the model
the central server sends that data
into different nodes
so there are subsets of the data
across different compute instances
and each compute instance trains a model
which is then aggregated into a single
final model
this is really awesome because it solves
that scale scalability issue
we can leverage horizontal scaling and
we can add more and more nodes and get
more and more compute so this can make
it more efficient and potentially less
costly but we're still sending our
sensitive data to a central server and
there's still more risk for server-side
attack or
security around each of the individual
compute instances so it increases our
exposure
in all of these scenarios we are sending
our data
to the model but what if we could
send the model to our data
that's what Federated learning does so
with Federated learning you have the
same setup you have a central server
and all of the different you know
devices that have this personal data but
rather than sending your personal data
to the central server
each of the devices will locally train a
model using just the data that is on
that device
so the server never touches the data
instead
the devices send the server model
weights after it's finished training of
the local model and the server
Aggregates all of those model weights to
create a new set of parameters which it
then sends back down to the clients or
the devices
so rather than the server containing all
of our data it actually now just
contains the only things that they it
needs for the model which is the model
weights and metrics and that creates a
final model
when I first learned this I was like why
are we not using Federated learning all
the time
as a consumer this makes me feel a
little bit better about the fact that my
data isn't just everywhere
but the truth is that there are
drawbacks to Federated learning that
make it difficult to implement the first
one being compute
so with Federated learning the
training isn't happening on
a compute instance that you know you own
and you can control but is rather using
the compute on the devices where the
data lies and so if there isn't enough
compute then that means that you may not
be able to train the model
or it may be very slow
the second one is networking
with
traditional machine learning and
distributed machine learning typically
you just need to send the data to the
server
that's one call
but with Federated learning there's a
constant communication between the
server and the different devices so if
you have a slow networking or unreliable
networking then it can pose some issues
the best places to use it is therefore
in these red taped Industries which is
exactly what my team did we ended up
having to work on a healthcare project
where we were tasked with building a
model
that would predict the likelihood of
breast cancer within the next five years
when we were tasked with this we had to
figure out what tools to use and we
ended up evaluating three main choices
the First Choice was Pi sift
pie sift was originally designed for
working with pi torch lightning but now
handles tensorflow as well but we found
that the documentation was a little
difficult for us to navigate and it was
going major undergoing major changes
the next one we evaluated was tensorflow
Federated but the major drawback was it
only worked with tensorflow and we were
considering using pi torch lightning for
training
that's when we came across a third
option which was a relatively new
package that was quickly gaining steam
within the Federated learning community
which is called flower
was framework agnostic so it would work
with tensorflow or part torch lightning
or any other framework that we needed
and it also had really clean and
thorough documentation
it was built around research purposes by
researchers in Germany so we felt like
it fit our needs for the exploratory
phase of our project
and
it also allowed us to quickly
interchange between different features
around the server configuration
so we chose flour
the way flower Works under the hood is
it has we have a flower server and then
flower clients which are the different
devices where the data is held and each
of those clients train a model
the central server has to grab
parameters from one of the clients so
it'll initialize by taking it from the
first client it connects to
and then it'll send down
the parameters to all of the clients
once they've connected in order to
instantiate the first round of training
each of the devices will train a model
and then they'll do the evaluation you
can also do evaluation on the server
itself rather than on the client side
but you would need data on the server
after the out valuation rounds are done
they send back parameters to the central
server which then applies an averaging
function in order to create the final
model
you can Define how many rounds you want
to train it and the more rounds that you
train it typically it'll get better
until a certain point
so if you wanted to do another round you
would train the model and run the
evaluation and then the devices would
send back the parameters to the flower
server
flour allows you to quickly aggregate
your metrics
so you can figure out different formulas
and Define that on the server
you can also aggregate the model weights
with using different averaging functions
and you can compress the model weights
to allow for a faster communication
between the server and the devices
so the best way to understand flower in
my opinion is through a demo so I've put
together a demo with using a
containerized application and an already
built model to demonstrate exactly what
flower can do with view lines of code
so just give me a second while I pull up
the repo
[Music]
okay
um
oh wait
Okay so
in this repo we have
um existing code that you don't
necessarily need to worry about we have
the model and you know the data sets for
each of the clients and code around how
that each client is configured so this
is all using exactly what they have in
their documentation but just fit to the
sample data set that I have and these
should be pretty recognizable features
for people who do machine learning but
it just has a fit and evaluate function
and besides that if we wanted to start
we would start with configuring our
server and the way to do that with
flower is after you import it you okay
just want to make sure
you use the server sub module and you
start the server
by defining a server address
so
oh yes thank you so much
um that's also a great idea how do I dim
the lights
this is
that better
[Music]
oh
I'm I'm okay with off if everyone can
see it
yeah I can definitely is that better
okay thanks everyone I appreciate it
um okay
so we're gonna just Define our server on
our local or zero zero zero
and port 8080
and then we have to give it a config so
the config has basically two settings a
timeout which I am not going to use but
the more important one is actually the
number of rounds so as we discussed
you can send the model weights from the
server to the client that's one round so
I'm gonna say let's do it for three
rounds just so we can see
better results and also a strategy
so
the strategy is actually the averaging
function that the server will use in
order to
aggregate the model weights after each
round is complete before sending the new
weights back down to all of the clients
so the
um the common one is just Federated
averaging which is a you know simple
averaging formula but they do have more
complex ones and they do allow you to
Define your own and
you can tell it how many clients to
expect
oh yeah I have to say
strategy
sorry and
and you can tell it how many clients to
apply the fit too so how many you want
to use for evaluation and fit I'm just
going to do fit the same as the number
of available clients which is three
and then you can bring up your server
um since I'm using Docker compose I just
am bringing up the server using the
service
which I've defined for flower this repo
is on GitHub and I'll share the link
after in case you want to actually
understand under the hood what's going
on there
but once we start the server we see that
it knows that it has to run for three
rounds
and that it's waiting for initial
parameters from one random client
so now we have to kind of make sure
create our first client and make sure
that it has connected to the server
so to do that
we just have to
use the flower server
and then do you use the client
function and we're going to start a
numpy client
but you can also just start a normal
client I just still selected numpy
because that was the example that my
team has used
you need to give it the server address
so because
ah thank you is that better
um so I'm using a docker
um container and so I'm just gonna tell
the server address as the docker
constraint container name but otherwise
if you have
networking setup then you can kind of
put it to wherever the address is
and then
I also need to give it a client so
that means that I have to create an
instance of
the client that I have defined already
which is our mnist client and it
um
inherits from this Base Class that gives
you all of these different properties
and all it does is
it allows the server to get weights if
the server needs a set of Weights which
ours does currently and it fits the
model and does the evaluation on the
client side
so for a client we can say we need
the mnis client
and
the one thing that I need to provide the
mnis client is some device name or ID
since I'm going to be spinning up three
of these
so I'm going to say that our device ID
is just going to be whatever I put into
the terminal
[Music]
and I'm put on
oh hold on yeah we do need to give it a
device ID but I have a client config so
I'm going to give it there
client config
the client config has
um
[Music]
it has different configurations that you
would need
for the client so
the server address is here it takes in
the device ID which we're going to give
it and then different hyper parameters
for your clients you can have different
hyper parameters for each of the models
for our three devices but we're just
going to stick with the same ones but
know that you can actually change up the
hyper parameters as long as a model
architecture stays the same
so with this
we should have a configured client when
we run our script to start up our first
client so
we're going to give it
the script and then device ID one so
this is our first device and if the code
works
we should see that it is connected to
the server and it is fetching its
parameters and then sending it to the
flower server
so the flower server now has a set of
parameters and we just need to
give it two more clients since we've
said that we want three clients
so to do this
I'm going to then connect a second
client and call it device two
and then give it a third client
and after this third client we should
see that the three rounds are kicking
off and that we're getting a fit and
evaluate three times
before the server closes so we can see
that we
the training has run
for each of the clients so each of the
clients will have this kind of output
and
our server will automatically shut down
it'll give us the losses over the three
rounds so you can see that the loss is
minimizing every time and if we actually
give it a way to
aggregate the metrics it will also give
us a metrics distribution which I will
show you
on a different branch because I don't
have the code for it off the top of my
head
but this is essentially all you need to
get started with a server and a client
so
to
see how it would work with
in a metrics aggregation function
um
I will show you
the piece of code that you would need
this is more just
neater code to create the server but we
can evaluate we can start with a
weighted average function and pass that
in to our
server or our strategy that we
initialized for the server and this
evaluate metrics aggregation function
will then provide a weighted average so
then this metrics distributed will also
be populated and you'll be able to see
how the metrics have improved over each
round
so if we wanted to start our server
again
and connect our three clients
so
it's fetching the data every time
because I'm using
a dummy data set
from scikit-learn or something I think
but
this time after
the third client has connected
we will see
the metrics improve hopefully
so this time we're logging accuracy but
you can see that the accuracy of the
model has improved over each round as
well so you can play with different
configurations like the number of rounds
or even what aggregation function you
want to use for your metrics when the
server has collected all of them and
wants to kind of output the final
metrics distribution
and that is and then you can also play
with the hyper parameters on the client
side if you wanted to further improve
the model
the other thing you could do which is
not related to flower but is related to
just machine learning in general is you
can obviously add more data and add more
devices and connect to your server to
multiple devices flower makes it really
easy to scale for thousands and
thousands of clients it has a few
server-side configurations that you can
find in their documentation
in order to kind of quickly connect to
thousands of clients so
that is the demo on flower and if you
can turn the lights back on
um while I get the presentation back up
okay
so overall
um you can see that flower helps us with
the scalability issue and it also helps
us with data privacy since the server
never touches the pro the user's data
and now you don't really have to worry
about security around the server when it
comes to data breaches because there is
no data on your server
so
overall
we can
kind of feel more confident as consumers
I think when
understanding that there are options out
there in the future for how to protect
some of our sensitive data while getting
the benefits of AI
if you want to use the code that we just
walked through then feel free to copy
down the tiny URL it contains the link
to the GitHub repo that has a
containerized application
and this is my contact and my company's
name is kung fu AI if you want to learn
anything more feel free to talk to me
and yeah that's it I'm open for
questions
um yes
in your demo but is flower also updating
the models on the client side after
every iteration of training yeah it'll
send forward like a new set of weights
to each of the clients and the clients
will take those set of Weights that's
part of like that flower abstract based
class
um and it'll like then kick off a new
round of training with those weights
model weights could be different
on each client
um yeah the model weights are different
on each client because it's fitting to
the data like that's locally on that
device but when you um
or
yeah so with the way that flowers like
natively set up from our team's
experience you send them it kind of
kicks off each round at the same time
which can cause an issue if like one
client is a little bit slower or has
like a lot more data but my team
actually figured out a way to kind of
make it asynchronous so they're
publishing a paper so I'll make sure to
put in the GitHub repo in the readme if
you're interested
thank you
any other questions
on the scale especially like with
I actually don't have metrics so the
question was like if there are metrics
to compare the networking speed between
maybe using a classical machine learning
approach and Federated learning
I don't have metrics since we were not
able to use classical Memphis machine
learning we were bound to Federated
learning because we were working with
Healthcare data for our project but I'd
be interested to know if there are
experiences out there with that
okay I think that oh yeah
oh okay yeah so the initial model
weights come from the very first client
that connects to the server
alternatively you can kind of initialize
the server with model weights but I
believe you have to have like data that
you've trained on on that server so if
you don't have any data then typically
like it'll default to waiting for that
first client and grabbing its parameters
yeah yeah exactly it's just waiting on a
random client like that's what the logs
say so you can control that a bit but
the default is just it'll take it from
any client and basically those initial
parameters are one client's specific
parameters to that data so
thank you I'm wondering if you could
talk a little bit about like how these
tools could be useful
like maybe in
context where like data privacy isn't as
valuable like I think like certainly
that's an emergency Trend but there's
also like other sides to this that are
valuable and I'm just curious
yeah so the question was are there use
cases for Federated learning outside of
um scenarios where data privacy is the
concern
um I believe that it's being used a lot
with like iot where it can but I think
that you know
because you have to like set up the
clients and you have to do the
networking it's not really the default I
kind of was expecting like I was kind of
hoping like self-driving cars would use
it because there's like a lot of data on
there but um because you have to be with
Wi-Fi it's kind of hard so
I I haven't really heard of actually too
many use cases besides Siri Siri is
trained using Federated learning and
they were able to kind of improve its
ability to pick up on your voice by
using your data and only training the
model locally but I think other than
that I actually don't know of any other
like cases outside of the highly
regulated Industries
okay well
if there are another questions thank you
everyone for attending my talk and I
hope that you enjoy the rest of Pi data
Seattle
thank you